bonjour l'afrique du sud est désormais
le pays d'afrique le plus touché par la
pandémie les échos publics ferment donc
de nouveau pour un mois et ce qu'il faut
s'attendre selon vous un confinement
très strictes à venir comme ce fut le
cas en mars dernier
la situation est certes très alarmant
parce que être cinquième au monde et
premier sur le continent africain n'est
pas ainsi une bonne gestion de la crise
même si loin mais avait félicité
l'afrique du sud dans la première vague
de contamination de colonna virus sur
son sur son sol le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui
l'afrique du sud est en train de
d'essayer de gérer une vague de
contamination une seconde vague de
contaminations dont elle ne sait pas
encore précisément combien de temps ça
lui prendra pour l'endiguer mais le fait
est que il ya deux afrique du sud et à
l'afrique je suis des cartes postales et
à l'afrique du sud et en chine
celle des bidonvilles où l'accès aux
médecins
et puis surtout la volonté d'aller dans
les hôpitaux est beaucoup moins forte
que dans les grandes villes et donc tous
ces éléments-là concourt à faire que
dans le cas de l'afrique du sud
aujourd'hui on se demande si les
statistiques sont exactement fidèle à la
situation de la pandémie sur le terrain
ou si ses statistiques ou ses
statistiques statistik la minimise les
données qui sont sur le terrain
mais un fait est certain c'est que
l'afrique du sud fera beaucoup d'efforts
pour ne pas être déclassé une fois de
plus elle a été pendant très longtemps
la première économie du continent
africain
elle a été déclassé par le nuage hier et
avec la crise sanitaire
elle risque de perdre encore quelques
rangs donc même si un confinement
je pense qu'il ne sera pas de très
longue durée dans les quartiers pauvres
du pays la situation se dégrade des gens
en peine à s'alimenter il ya eu des
pillages et d'ailleurs avec la police
quelles solutions seront proposées aux
habitants de ce quartier est ce que les
mesures adoptées jusque là par le
gouvernement sont insuffisantes selon
vous
les mesures sont les musulmans pour
âgeuse elles sont à la hauteur d'un pays
comme l'afrique du sud qui est immense
et qui n'est pas à l'abri des cas de
contamination comme on en a vu dans
d'autres grandes puissances que ce soit
la france ou les états unis
ce n'est vraiment pas une exception mais
encore une fois l'afrique du sud des
bidonvilles ne se comportent pas de la
même manière que le reste de l'afrique
du sud qui a les moyens à la fois de se
soigner de se protéger de se protéger
par les gestes barrières les masques
ainsi que les gels ou le soin que l'on
porte aux mains l'autre dimension c'est
que l'afrique du sud est également un
pays où la xénophobie
après une très grande dimension dans les
premiers temps on a estimé que c'est à
cause des commerçants étrangers venus
des pays africains voisins que le
coronavirus était arrivé et donc du coup
il ya eu des espèces de montée de fièvre
de poussée de fièvre dans les
bidonvilles
ils se sont barricadés pour certains les
étrangers n'ont pas encore été attaquées
mais en fait est certain c'est que dans
ces bidonvilles
la police doit gérer à la fois la
pandémie mais surtout les peurs les
anxiétés de la population qui croît par
moments que les difficultés viennent de
l'extérieur
ce fut le cas par rapport au sida à la
pandémie de sida c'est le cas également
avec cette pandémie de coronavirus donc
l'enjeu pour les autorités sud
africaines
c'est à la fois dû rassurer les
populations par rapport à la manière
dont elle prend en charge la pandémie
mais également de les rassurer par
rapport au fait que les étrangers en
afrique du sud ne sont pas la principale
menace est le principal vecteur de la
pandémie alors d'un mois
s'il vous plaît le nombre d'infections
on l'a dit un parmi les soignants le
secteur hospitalier est en constante
augmentation on évoque donc plus de
13000 acteurs de la santé qui seraient
touchés par le coronavirus est ce que
les hôpitaux du pays où l'infrastructure
nécessaire pour en gérer une crise
sanitaire d'ampleur
aucun pays au monde ne peut aujourd'hui
dire qu'il a les moyens suffisants pour
gérer de façon irréprochable la pandémie
qui s'abat sur nous c'est une pandémie
que personne n'a prévu dont personne n'a
prévu l'ampleur
l'afrique du sud même si elle fait
partie des grandes puissances
économiques du continent africain reste
un pays qui en voie de développement
comme la russie elle est un pays
aujourd'hui qui fait partie des brics
mais cela ne signifie pas que sur tout
le territoire sud-africain les moyens de
l'état sont les mêmes
cela ne signifie pas que la prise de
conscience par rapport à la politique
sanitaire est la même au sein de la
population
donc il ya toutes ces inégalités là
qu'il faut gérer
malgré la bonne volonté du gouvernement
je pense qu'il y aura besoin de l'aide
des partenaires de l'afrique du sud la
banque africaine de développement a mis
la main à la poche
les autorités sont en train de prendre
le taureau par les cornes et j'espère
que les populations
suivront dans cette discipline qui fera
que tous les efforts seront conjugués
pour à la fois endiguer la pandémie mais
surtout la soigner complètement pour
qu'elle disparaisse du sol de l'afrique
du sud pour l'instant le président sud
africain a annoncé que non seulement
l'année scolaire va probablement aller
au delà de l'année 2020 mais il annonce
également que toutes les mesures seront
prises pour que les populations soient
saines et soignés et que la pandémie
soit contenue si beaucoup louis keumayou
président du club de l'information
africaine